This is a simple example where
we want to just apply the
formula for conditional
probabilities
and see what we get.
The example involves a
four-sided die, if you can
imagine such an object, which
we roll twice, and we record
the first roll, and
the second roll.
So there are 16 possible
outcomes.
We assume to keep things simple,
that each one of those
16 possible outcomes, each
one of them has the same
probability, so each outcome
has the probability 1/16.
Let us consider now a particular
event B on which
we're going to condition.
This is the event under which
the smaller of the two die
rolls is equal to 2, which means
that one of the dice
must have resulted in two, and
the other die has resulted in
something which is
2 or larger.
So this can happen
in multiple ways.
And here are the different
ways that it can happen.
So at 2, 2, or 2, 3, or 2, 4;
then a 3, 2 and a 4, 2.
All of these are outcomes in
which one of the dice has a
value equal to 2, and
the other die
is at least as large.
So we condition on this event.
This results in a conditional
model where each one of those
five outcomes are equally likely
since they used to be
equally likely in the
original model.
Now let's look at
this quantity.
The maximum of the
two die rolls--
that is, the largest
of the results.
And let us try to calculate
the following quantity--
the conditional probability that
the maximum is equal to 1
given that the minimum
is equal to 2.
So this is the conditional
probability of
this particular outcome.
Well, this particular outcome
cannot happen.
If I tell you that the smaller
number is 2, then the larger
number cannot be equal to 1, so
this outcome is impossible,
and therefore this conditional
probability is equal to 0.
Let's do something a little
more interesting.
Let us now look at the
conditional probability that
the maximum is equal to 3 given
the information that
event B has occurred.
It's best to draw a picture
and see what that event
corresponds to.
M is equal to 3--
the maximum is equal to 3--
if one of the dice resulted
in a 3, and the other die
resulted in something
that's 3 or less.
So this event here corresponds
to the blue
region in this diagram.
Now let us try to calculate the
conditional probability by
just following the definition.
The conditional probability of
one event given another is the
probability that
both of them--
both of the two events--
occur, divided by the
probability of the
conditioning event.
That is, out of the total
probability in the
conditioning event, we ask,
what fraction of that
probability is assigned to
outcomes in which the event of
interest is also happening?
So what is this event?
The maximum is equal to 3,
which is the blue event.
And simultaneously, the red
event is happening.
These two events intersect
only in two places.
This is the intersection
of the two events.
And the probability of that
intersection is 2 out of 16,
since there's 16 outcomes and
that event happens only with
two particular outcomes.
So this gives us 2/16
in the numerator.
How about the denominator?
Event B consists of a total
of five possible outcomes.
Each one has probability 1/16,
so this is 5/16, so the final
answer is 2/5.
We could have gotten that same
answer in a simple and perhaps
more intuitive way.
In the original model, all
outcomes were equally likely.
Therefore, in the conditional
model, the five outcomes that
belong to B should also
be equally likely.
Out of those five, there's two
of them that make the event of
interest to occur.
So given that we live in B,
there's two ways out of five
that the event of interest
will materialize.
So the event of interest has
conditional probability [equal to]
2/5.